um and you know what's so crazy it's
like
when I when I think of the people that
have like helped me like done the most
selfless things for me in my life
um it's been a lot of guys a lot of Matt
like when I think of like one of one of
the best people I know you know I talk
about them all the time but like is my
dad and like literally the most selfless
guy I've ever met at the grocery store
he'll like help strangers with their
groceries like carry them to the car he
he's Dr like he had an employee once who
um was moving across States and like my
dad like he worked for my dad they ended
up like switching jobs my dad drove them
like eight hours to help them move like
he's just that type of guy and they're
just surrounded they're one they behave
like women that don't deserve protection
or provisioning